[Applause]
the sunflower joined the shamrock and
yellow and blue tinged the green as the
first st patrick's day parade in three
years took place in dublin
members of the ukrainian community led
the parade with a message of solidarity
[Music]
the russian invasion has seen thousands
of refugees welcomed here and it's also
open to debate on one of the central
planks of ireland's identity its
neutrality
the javelin anti-tank missile being
fired by irish soldiers in county
wicklow ireland has a small stockpile of
the weapon but won't send any to ukraine
because ireland is a neutral country
it's a policy almost as old as the irish
state ireland was even neutral during
world war ii
now though with war in europe once more
it's suddenly being challenged
these are members of the army ranger
wing ireland's special forces
kahul berry used to be one of them now
he's a politician calling for a real
debate on neutrality absolutely to be
honest it's long past time and the
situation ukraine has really focused our
minds it's probably a defining moment
really and because let's remember russia
has threatened ireland as a member of
the eu for for slapping sanctions on the
kremlin and they could become very very
aggressive towards ireland in the next
few weeks it's important that we're able
to defend ourselves ireland has taken in
thousands of ukrainian refugees and is
spending more than 30 million euro in
aid
but when it comes to military equipment
it's restricted to non-lethal things
like body armor and rations
since the invasion of ukraine ireland's
military neutrality has been under
scrutiny like never before the irish
government says such a long-standing
policy can't be changed overnight but it
does now accept that it's up for debate
i think there's a there's certainly an
openness now in ireland uh to discuss
issues around common security and
defense in a way that is more proactive
and more open to
to to a change in policy and i think the
irish public will uh will be comfortable
with that given what we're seeing and
the brutality that we're seeing coming
from russia in ukraine right now
opinion is divided on the streets of
cork home to the country's naval base
i'm all fire neutrality aim i don't want
us to be giving that up or sacrificing
that in any way shape or form
when you see what's going on in ukraine
no no i think it's time to make a change
you know it's uh
we we need to mature ourselves i think
and and come along you know i disagree
totally absolutely keep our neutrality
absolutely
yeah
for now ireland remains in a crisis of
conscience dreading the line between its
much cherished neutrality and making a
more deadly contribution to the defense
of ukraine stephen murphy sky news in
dublin